[Music]
you guys and thanks for tuning in to ET
live I'm Katie Krauss and I'm really
excited today because Dylan Manette is
here from 13 reasons why yes cloud
you're out there I can hear you all the
way in here sorry for the the slight
delay I do want to let you guys know
though to send your questions in for
Dylan I'm gonna get them right here on
this iPad I'll make sure to ask them but
I want to get right into it first of all
congratulations season three thanks
stoked for you guys
season two though left off on some major
cliffhangers how do you feel about clays
rollercoaster ride in season two like
how do you feel about his journey man I
mean it was uh it was rough I mean we I
think we saw clay at kind of his lowest
of lows so we've seen him at before and
um you know in a lot of ways there's
kind of an even more difficult journey
than season one yeah I mean season one
was enough just having clay listen to
the tapes but I mean season everything
there's happening season two was clearly
taking a toll on clay and having you
know living with Han honest in his mind
yeah and and getting to the point where
she's reciting tape twelve over and over
to him and and just driving him to that
point of when he was standing outside
Bryce's house with a gun it's just I
don't think anyone who is following clay
wants to see him in that position so it
was really difficult you know is it was
kind of not not the it was it was a
really difficult season to shoot because
it was just really heavy all of it
I do feel like we saw so many emotions
from clay kind of talking about what
you're talking about the scene with the
gun where he's outside of Bryce's house
I mean we didn't really address his
mental health head-on though no why do
you think that was I think that it's not
fully recognized by himself or any the
character surrounding him yet not and
that's exactly something that I would
love to see explored with clay and
whether it be season 3 or how I mean I
don't know how long the show's gonna go
but like just at some point in the
future on the show that's something that
I would love to
because even back in episode 2 of season
1 there is a scene where his parents
refer to these like these meds that they
wanted to go back on and I think there
were four I think we're supposed to they
were for depression and we and we at
some point you know clearly clay was on
a medication at some point in its life
and isn't on it anymore and and I think
there's a lot of um a lot of issues
eclaim has a beep obvious to deal with
and have to be addressed and he really
needs help I mean season two if anything
was proof of that
yeah you know I think and that's it's
like to continue the conversation of you
know mental illness and everything I
think and really be explored through
clay there's a lot to be discussed with
him yeah how hard is that as an actor
for you at the end of the day I mean how
do you unwind from playing those types
of emotions oh I'm pretty good at
leaving it at work I think like I just
you know I don't know I it's difficult I
mean I'm definitely some who like dwells
on things and thinks about a lot of
scenes coming up like as soon as I got
the script for episode 11 with the gun
and everything I I just was thinking
about it non-stop it's gonna be the
hardest scene
I don't know if it ended up being that
but like and I don't know what the most
difficult thing I've ever had to shoot
is but that was I mean it was just one
of them I it's it's never had to like
hold a gun to my head before like that
and there was just a lot of that in
season two where you're going I've never
done anything like this yeah but I mean
honestly in season two I would I would
just go back and watch Big Brother you
know you know it shoots in this studio
right a big brother after-show are you
serious are you a fan actually am I'm
surprised to hear that I pleasure of
mine yeah I'm not guilty about it
although because I think it's like
reality show there is yeah it's gonna be
back on like next week you should do
Celebrity Big Brother next season it's
coming be a good move huh yeah it would
be yeah let's talk a little bit about
the finale and obviously there's the gun
in episode 11 but also the cliffhanger
of episode 13 how did you feel about
that ending you notice when he took on
that scene had a couple different forms
like when we first got the white draft
it was different from what it was pretty
different from what it
being what songs I don't know if I'm
really 8 like able to discuss that I
don't know if I don't know Brian would
be happy of me explaining like her
people would be happy makes me go I
think there were there were more people
involved like but and it ended up
becoming very much clay and Tyler and
which I think was really kind of
important because I think we're supposed
to know and believe that what clay did
is the wrong decision to make
they should have called the police they
should have lost they should have just
locked the doors inside called the
police and and and let everyone know
what was happening I mean I think that
we are not supposed to believe that clay
made the right decision even though it
was ultimately successful but we're
supposed to believe that that is a
decision that clay would make because he
is someone who acts on his emotions
without thinking his actions through
before he does them and really tries to
take everything on himself and I think
he was trying to make up for mistakes he
made in the past by not being there for
someone who really needs it and that's
what he's saying when you hear the
narration of his speech from Hannah's
memorial service that day yeah and so
clay just feels a responsibility to go
and save anyone he can and in doing that
they could have been it could have been
an extreme disaster
yeah and I mean I don't think clay
really knew what he was getting into I
walking outside bite I think he really
fully realized in a moment that he'd be
facing Tyler with an assault rifle right
in front of him but you know he could
have called the police and someone altum
Utley did inside as we know because the
police are on the way but you know I
just any it's it's a tricky scene
because me as as Dillon I'm going that
what is this is a horrible decision like
what is Cle doing but then you also have
to really believe what you're doing in
in playing clay in that scene so I have
to really kind of get to a place of
believing what I'm doing is right - in
the scene but I don't know I mean as
long as people know that like that's we
know that that is a not the right
decision you know and nobody should ever
try and go and confront anyone who is
carrying a weapon so how do you feel
about people who are criticizing the
show for almost empathizing with Tyler's
character and his intent to even go to
the show and
yeah where to the school sorry I mean I
don't know I think like no one's
opinions are invalid I think that anyone
who has an opinion and had in a starting
discussion than is debating this with
someone I think that's healthy mmm-hmm
you know I can't really speak on why
certain decisions are made on the show
the way they are I just have to you know
kind of be there and believe in what
we're doing and I do I mean I think it's
it's a way of it's a way of how you look
at it and if you're empathizing with
Tyler and I mean like obviously you're
not on anyone else aside in the bathroom
scene but manure about it for me it's
not really about empathizing Tyler but
just recognizing that there are many
different ways that a monster can be
formed or that's what can bring a
monster out of someone and to me the way
that I view this season overall is how
like involving weapons and everything is
how dangerous it can be when kids who
are so destructive and so emotionally
confused can easily access weapons like
this and really what weapons of mass
destruction like like assault rifles and
that is that's at least how I view this
and I would like to see that discussed
in future seasons or at least be address
because I've been saying it's like it's
the show it is difficult because it's
it's like it has to walk if I mind you
it can't be it can't be just a PSA or
shoving messages on people's throats or
else then it's just not compelling
televisions like you have to find this
this rap this fine line where it's
compelling TV and also discussing the
topics that it does with with truth I
mean with with grace and I think that
could be addressed and I think it will
be and that's just how I view it yeah
how did you feel about the bathroom
scene when you first read it I mean it's
gotten a lot of people talking yeah yeah
I mean I remember and I heard about the
idea I was like I don't think there's
any way that's gonna make it in I would
be shocked
I remember reading the script and
reading it being halfway through and
then seeing the Tyler first gets his
head bashed into the mirror and then in
the sink twice and then dragged to the
toilet and his head dunked him and I was
taking myself oh they totally did this
because they
got rid of the mop bit cuz he Wow - and
then it got to the mop that as well I
remember schooling just not being
prepared for the extinct that that scene
goes to it's just it's really really
brutal and I remember just being shocked
and angry and confused and conflicted on
whether I thought it needed to be there
but then the more I talked to Brian and
talked to everyone I understood why it
was there and um and I really and I
think that it was shot really tastefully
I mean Kyle Alvarez is such a amazing
director he also did the finale of
season one which is really tricky and I
think just the way it was shot is the
best way that it could have been done
but I remember just being feeling the
emotions that I think we're supposed to
feel when we either read or watch that
scene and that's shocked confused angry
sad disturbed you know going to the very
end of the finale then and you have
Tyler and you have clay standing outside
of the school Tyler leaves and you have
the gun where do you think the story
goes from there I don't know where
should it go
I don't know okay I don't know I think
um you know III don't I'd be surprised
if the story is an immediate like
immediately picks up where it left off I
feel like the 13 reasons life fashion is
there's a time jump and we just put
together the pieces of what happened in
between
I don't know I'm not confirming but
that's right I feel like it's going huh
yeah I don't know I don't know what clay
knows that kind of how he gets out of it
when we were filming it I did not
realize that the sirens would sound that
close yeah I was like wait I've no they
must run right right cut scatter site I
don't know yeah yeah
I spoke with Devon droid and he says
that he hopes next season that the
aftermath of male sexual assaults is
covered extensively how do you feel
about that I mean we saw it with Jessica
just sexual assault and what a beautiful
job that she did this season
some of Jessica's stuff is just my
favorite stuff of the season yeah I mean
I definitely I think it's only natural
that that would be addressed and
discussed in season three and um it's
really interesting to me because I feel
like that's not something that's
addressed on television or in
entertainment all the time so I think
it's something - absolutely discuss and
talk about and it's actually an exciting
idea to me I mean it's it's a sad you
know story but it's exciting to me to be
able to address that on the show yeah
another major storyline of course the
trial this season and Bryce kind of gets
off with three months probation a slap
on the wrist which really is a realistic
depiction of what happens how did you
feel about that
I mean I was obviously upset but I was
happy that that was the outcome for a
storytelling sake because it's that's
just what that's just what happens I
mean it's just very rarely do people
like Bryce get the punishment they
deserve because I mean people either
afraid or people don't take it seriously
enough and it's really disheartening and
I was happy that they decided to make
that decision and not go the UM not go
the happy ending round because it hardly
ever has a happy ending but I think they
did it perfectly because they also
showed that Jessica felt powerful
and felt like she was finding closure
and and found a sense of community and
everyone was there for her and supported
her and going to the police so it's like
yes Bryce didn't get the punishment he
deserved which is real life and but but
showed the Jessica still found her piece
and and and and some power and what she
did and a sense of community and that
can still happen so even if the outcome
even if the villain doesn't get the
punishment they deserve you can still
overcome these things and you can still
feel a power and coming out and stepping
forward and saying saying something yeah
yeah it's interesting that you say that
I was talking to somebody earlier and we
said that exact same thing that you do
see this piece sort of come through when
Jessica does come forward and when
Justin helps her but you still also feel
so agitated and you know there are
criticisms out there that are
people gonna be discouraged to come
forward right how do you respond to that
well I think I understand that um but I
think I mean I think that that's why the
show did the best it could to show that
Jessica felt peace and showing that like
at the end of the day it doesn't really
it there will be people there for you
you know there will be people there for
you as long as you feel power and coming
forward and there's and there will be
people there to support you and believe
you and hear you in the entire process
and no matter what the outcome of you
know whoever these horrible attackers
are so sure we're gonna take some fan
questions okay all right Desiree says
Dylan I love your band wallows you guys
teased on insta that you're almost done
recording one can we expect new music
and the next question wouldn't ask you
later okay about it's about the music -
hmm when we'd spent new music I think as
from an album standpoint not too soon
just because I gotta go I gotta go film
and stuff I'm gonna go film Thursdays on
this show but as soon as I'm like free
and we're it's gonna be a whole it's
gonna be a whole lab we're gonna do a
big tour shindig mix ru album release
everything it's gonna happen it's all
getting set up but well at least put out
definitely put on some music before that
though there's definitely music and
stuff in the pipeline coming out that
isn't necessarily album related yet but
there's there stuff coming a new music
video yeah yeah yeah like next week I
think Oh music video that's awesome yeah
alright I'm always in forever on YouTube
says was there a scene that you film
that was really difficult for you so so
many there's so many I mean one that
comes to mind cuz it's like the most
rash is I think the last scene of the
show Tyler just it was a really
intimidating standing up you know I mean
Devon's just incredible in that scene
and and he's he's really horrifying and
that's a man standing in front of him
was really jarring and and it didn't it
really helped me out because in losing
my words and being scared because he was
just
he really scared me in that scene and
that's exactly what he should have done
so that was difficult to navigate you
also wanna make sure it feels real and
honest and then I fully believe where
clay is coming from so for me right now
it's that I mean but there's so many
there's just so many scenes in the show
that it's just takes a toll yeah yeah
for sure some of the scenes that I loved
were between clay and Justin a new
friendship that was kind of formed yeah
how was that for you and what do you
love about that friendship oh man I mean
like well I love Brandon first and
foremost but I think it's a cool I mean
I what I think is really cool is that
the first person that you see clay
interact with in the show is Justin back
in episode 1 mm-hmm
clay searing your hands Walker and
Justin goes up says what the hell are
you doing like you're not innocent I
don't care what she says and that
relationship between clean Justin and
season one is they hate each other they
couldn't hate each other more clay its
Justin Justin aids clay and I think it's
really I think one of the least explain
my least expected things I one of most
unexpected things would be for clay and
Justin to become family and also you
know I think that Justin and clay both
saved each other in season 2 I mean
Justin's the one who talked clay down
from either killing Bryce or killing
himself and clay is the one who went and
got Justin off the street and tried to
clean him up and and and be there for
him although we saw it to me leave that
Justin is still reverting back to old
habits but they needed each other and
who would have thought that those two
people would be would end up needing
each other in order to I don't know like
even live right I'm excited to see I'm
sure they'll be like roommates still in
season 3 cool I'm hoping for that but
are we gonna see him in recovery in
season 3 do you think I don't know III
did there's a lot I don't know about
season 3 I there's actually I mostly
don't know anything about season 3 but
um I I don't know okay I mean I hope so
I mean I I'm really sad that in season 3
one thing we do know is that Katherine
Langford will not be back she confirmed
that news
to us what was that like on set I mean
did she talk to you guys was there some
sort of like speech that happened or how
are you feeling about that you know it's
it's it's interesting because on the the
last scene she filmed was the one in the
church but I think I don't think anyone
was willing to completely out of the
anyone was even like allowed to
necessarily just like outright say
that's her last scene so it's like it
unfortunately that her last scene didn't
really get the last scene treatment like
it was more of like that's a season wrap
on Kathryn and not that's a series of
epic Effie because we didn't know like
nobody really knew we knew but like
anything was possible and needed to be
approved but you know it's like it's
just you don't know so it was I think we
sort of knew and she knew I knew
everyone the cast just knew so we like
we were all treating it that way
personally but you couldn't outright be
like this is our last scene because it's
like nobody really knows but um we we
knew and I knew kind of more at the
beginning of season 2 that that would be
the end of um of Hanna's Road you know
the end of Hannah's story once clay is
able to let her go I love that letter
the 13 or the 11 reasons why not yeah
call me on a super powerful reading that
13th script was so I was just alone in
my apartment up there just reading it
just like crying so sad I mean it's I
mean it is it's so touching it so
emotional what would you be open to the
idea of a spin-off series that was 11
reasons why not do you think there's
room for that story and that she could
be involved in that I just don't see how
that would be possible like if she were
to choose differently I mean I think
like I think I think what's more
important as I've been continuing on the
story retelling in that we just were
able to acknowledge and recognize that
all the reasons why not you know and
that that letter is there and that we
can read that and know that that was
better that's kind of what mrs. Baker
says Sam there's always more reasons why
not doesn't matter how many reasons you
think there are why there's always more
why not and I think that's I think
that's all we need to recognize
I think we learn I think we can learn
more and take more with us by having us
only know what Hanna could have done
better and not not see it that's just me
I mean that's it's just that's just a
rather fine closure in other ways I feel
I was very surprised by the I think a
lot of people are very surprised by the
Zak and Hannah romance why do you think
that wasn't even hinted at really in
season one you know I don't know I think
I think it's one of those things that
it's like there could be arguments as to
why Hannah didn't bring it up on her
tape and I think I don't know I think
it's just one of those things we're
supposed to not necessarily have to
understand why she didn't bring it up I
think that's something that only Hannah
knew and only she'll know why she didn't
put it on there for and I think like I
mean and there's also a way to look at
it that it didn't really help her case
on her tape it didn't really help her
side of the story that she was trying to
tell ya you know that Zak apologized and
everything I think if she's trying to
tell a tape about Zak and why he was a
part of why she personally took her own
life then in her mind then the part of
the story is where he didn't apologize
because I think we realize he's do not
everything Hannah told was exactly the
truth she told her truth and maybe the
way she understood things but for her
maybe the part of what they had during
that summer wasn't a part of the reason
yeah do you think that clay is in a
place where he could have another love
interest in season three I think if
there is potential I think clay would
definitely probably try to avoid it at
this point I think I imagine the last
thing clay he's gonna want right now
given his past record so far is is a lot
of interest but I think maybe he won't
be able to avoid it you know I know
I'll see you one thing that Catherine
told me last week actually was that she
hopes to still be involved with social
media at least next season and that she
feels I think a responsibility to keep
interacting with the fans what type of
weight do you feel on your shoulders and
are
people approaching you for advice for
help ever and how do you handle that
not so much approaching me for advice
I'm sure that there are maybe like I
mean I I don't see as much of people
reaching out for advice but I think as
long as you are a positive figure there
for people and and people that and and
some of the people feel like they can
just be just being a positive presence
on people's whether it be timelines or
just for them and also make sure that
those links and and and resources are
provided for people if they need it and
that you know just being just being a
positive figure especially being part of
a show that is so honest and at times
very negative just being somebody could
be there for these people and if someone
were to ever come out to me for advice
I'd love to speak to them and then to me
but no one really has yeah it's more so
just a lot of people come up and thank
you for the show and explain what it did
for them and that's always incredible to
hear and it just makes me realize how
you know important like projects can
really be and how important this you
know this this art form can really be
arrests beforehand I didn't really
recognize that but the show makes me
realize that it can be really helpful
for people on that kind of same level of
course there's PSAs now at the beginning
of the series do you feel like that's
enough I mean I don't I haven't really
thought about it that much because I
just don't know I don't know what else
it could really I mean they because they
have the resource at the end of every
episode and then they'll put trigger
warnings before episodes that have like
outright you know scenes that exactly
exactly
you know I don't know I think I think
that I think it's really kind of
difficult probably I don't know what
goes on to Netflix in behind this in how
how what goes into it but I'm sure
they're doing I think they're doing the
best that they that they can you know
and without plastering at all of our
scenes on the show you know they're
doing everything they can to not be
intrusive but to also be out of it yeah
so yeah we're gonna take a few more of
these Tara on YouTube says
has acting on the show affected your own
personal life because of the themes this
show goes into it's a good question I
mean if anything it's um it's just
really I mean if anything has just been
really enlightening I mean I've just
learned so much from being on the series
and knowing you know and just ends up
being forced to recognize and learn the
extent that the extent of people that
that are affected by all the issues in
the show whether it be depression or
whether it be suicide attempts whether
it be sexual assault it's just I'm if
anything just thankful and happy to be a
part of a show that that addresses these
issues head-on yeah and it doesn't act
like they don't exist and and it's just
it's just really helped me learn a lot
and he goes back to like being think 'fl
to be a part of a show like to kind of
be there for these people if they need
it yeah I do love that the show tackles
these issues head-on
I mean bullying teen homelessness yeah
heroin addiction it's a lot but critics
do think that you guys don't address it
enough that you sort of gloss over some
of the issues how do you respond to that
critique do you think that will evolve
or change in season three I mean it's I
to me it like I said is just a personal
thing because I I have no I really don't
have control over what happens in the
show and and it's it's I just I'm along
for the ride and you know I hope
everyone recognizes that but I you know
it's like I said I I just think it's a
really it's a really fine line that the
show and the writers have to walk I mean
it's it's you want to make compelling
television and it is entertainment at
the end of the day but it also is really
important and it's like you just got to
find this balance of how much do you
lean into you just don't want it to
become like your end up talking down to
people because then if it becomes like a
PSA or just like or something like that
then I think it would also be critiqued
for not being real or just seeming like
it's they I think it would also get
criticized for being too much of a PSA
yeah I think there's no winning I think
if you were addressing these top
six on a show I mean I think a lot of
people aren't used to it and it doesn't
really happen that often especially like
surrounding teens on a television series
and the way the show does and I just
think that no matter how you do it
there's going to be an equal amount of
critique and controversy even even if we
were doing what those critics say we
should do I think they'd also be
criticizing for doing it too much well
one thing that they are appraising is
your performance I mean everyone's just
said that you've done an incredible job
Emmy nominations are coming up do you
think about that no no I mean like it's
just the last thing I'd ever expect just
for that to happen I mean yeah I mean
that'd be awesome I'd be there and
totally it would be cool would be really
honored but I just that's the last thing
I expect yeah but I mean hey I'm really
happy that um people are responding and
people actually a lot of really kind
things about like my performance
everyone else in performances and it's
just not me I mean like the one thing
that I think no but like critics nobody
can deny and I think can easily be
overlooked a little bit just because
there is so much on this there is so
much of the show that can leave it up to
a lot of debate leave it up for a lot of
debate to people and that the amount of
talent on the show I think could be
easily overlooked sometimes because
people are distracted by other things
and I think that the the cast and the
crew the writers behind the show it
really is second to none and I think
that like especially in season two the
performances are just through the roof
like on everyone's part and I'm just so
happy to be a part of such a talented
cast and stuff and it just me inspired
me to come to work every day and do the
best job I can do so it's it's not just
me man it's it's Louie everybody on the
show and I mean everyone involved with
the show and I think that's what really
also really keeps the show flow and I
think like I think like I'm not like
just the talent behind it you know it's
like and not just in the acting writing
directing all of it and I think that
that's what a lot of people can also
recognize is the amount of work that
really goes into it and trying to just
make sure we're also making a really
really great show so everyone's doing
the best their abilities I think it was
really good everyone is great agree with
you we talked a little bit earlier about
music
are the chances that maybe in season 3
we'll get to either see a cameo from the
wallows on the show I mean we saw the
punk-rock Club we know but it exists or
maybe on the soundtrack yeah you'd be up
for that I hate to break hearts but now
really you want to keep them separate
yeah they're separate yeah I think a lot
of people would hate me if I put the
music on the show and rightfully so so
it's not something I'm gonna I'm gonna
attempt it's too meta it's too mad at
you know it's like it's if clays crying
there's like a sad wall of song in the
background I would probably never be
able to watch that show right I see what
you mean
um and then before we wrap up here maybe
just two things that you would love to
see clay tackle in season 3 oh I mean
well like I said I think I think there's
room I'd be surprised if the show didn't
go into exploring you know whatever
issues clay has but I think that there's
a lot to be addressed with clay I mean I
think like even see him in therapy at
some point or something just being
having someone to talk to and having
clay be able to face you know these
problems that he has I don't know if
that's gonna happen season 3 I have no
idea I just think that that's something
that I'd love to see explore with clay
kind of powers saying earlier yeah I
mean I feel like you know if it was
season 2 clay was I'm really carrying
the weight of Hannah still obviously
more than before more than ever before
and other that's gone I see kind of clay
being a little wiser a little more
grown-up given everything he's gone
through still like that was the case of
season 2 after season 1 now it's even
especially the case I've just season two
and just seeing how he deals with this
moving forward in his life and not
having not carrying the guilt and weight
of Hannah anymore and and just seeing
what new challenges await for him even
though aren't involving Hannah because
we know I think if anyone expects clay
to have an easy path and any season we
know we're wrong I think that season 3
he's definitely not gonna be easy for
clay or any of these people if it if it
was I don't think we'd be out of the
be the show anymore well and the writers
now know what you're capable of so I
mean I man I'm just nervous to know what
clay is gonna go through and we can't
wait to watch it
wait till 2019 but I appreciate you
being here so thank you so much thank
you guys for watching make sure that you
keep up with Dylan on all social media
you have Instagram you have Twitter
other things all there and of course
season two of thirteen reasons why
streaming now on netflix and if you do
need help or resources there's also
links that you guys can check out so
thanks for watching thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]